and uh what i wanted to talk about is
a little introduction to the precision
medicine topic in general why
bioinformatics in precision medicine
but also to tell you briefly about what
the program is going to help you with
uh when you are joining this training
program so
before i uh go there our background is
we're a technology transfer company and
we have a close collaboration with
university of haifa the tower
bioinformatics research center which is
a
center dedicated to the development of
computational tools and algorithms
and also making them available in a use
easy to use
way for many users that do not have an
engineering and a bioinformatics
background
and essentially the objective of the
omics logic program that we developed
is to help with training in
bioinformatics
to enable independent research that is
guided by mentors and pure example
we want to develop a community that is
thriving and growing
and they share a passion for data-driven
research and an appreciation of
citizen science which means that not
just scientists
doing science but people that are
learning about
science are also engaged in that process
and then we also want to make sure that
we are enabling students clinicians and
faculty of all backgrounds
to develop novel independent research
using latest technology in life and
data sciences which means to make it
more accessible and more
user-friendly and so today we're
speaking about precision medicine and i
want to briefly talk about
why bioinformatics and precision
medicine i mean
if you're interested in precision
medicine maybe you're a clinician maybe
you're a student in biotechnology
maybe you're just interested in
applications of
data for the biomedical research and so
the question is well why bioinformatics
so what we want to talk about today is
how
essentially the availability of data and
high throughput computational
resources and computational
resources that can analyze and integrate
and visualize this data
is actually driving a new approach to
using data for clinical purposes and so
to describe what that really means
i want to take a couple of examples and
then i'll pass it on to
some of our mentors to speak more in
depth about their particular examples
with research studies they've been
involved in
so let's take an example with cancer
right we know that
cancer incidence and mortality is
growing
specifically it is growing in countries
that have
already good health care systems they
have a lot of research
and the major driving force behind that
is the growing and aging population so
the percentage of people that are older
typically that is seen as one of the
driving reasons why
the number of cancer patients and
mortality rates are increasing
now how do you leverage the
ability of these countries to understand
and study these diseases
to address such a pressing challenge
that is only bound to continue and grow
and become more
complex in the future well one of the
things that
is now obvious about cancer is that the
earlier we understand that cancer
risk is increasing and the earlier we
can detect
the specific type of cancer that is
developing
we can develop markers of cancer risk
and we start
addressing that cancer earlier on and
that is a proven way
to address cancer mortality and
treatment in a more efficacious way
and so this early diagnosis really
starts very early
and maybe for some cancers including
cancers that children have
this is a very critical point so we need
the ability to screen but obviously we
cannot screen for everything
we need to know what we're looking for
and so the basis
of this data-driven and biomarker
medicine is really having access to data
and so in the past a couple of decades i
think the
major exciting thing that has been
happening
is that next-generation sequencing as a
technology has been refined
to the point that it is becoming
accessible enough and affordable enough
so it is
really entering the clinical domain and
so it is entering
with this diversity and challenge
that a technology like next generation
sequencing is can bring because
essentially next generation sequencing
can be used
to generate a diverse set of data and so
that brings us to this point of omics
data so why
omics data and as you know we're called
onyx logic so a lot of this program is
going to be focused on mixed data
so onyx means a collection
a collection of the totality of
something and so it could really refer
to
a number of different things for example
we can say phenomics
which is the collection of phenotypes
because really when we look
at cells let's say coming from a tumor
or the micro environment
they have different morphology they they
have different characteristics
that we can define in different ways and
so we can collectively call that
phenomics the collection of phenotypes
about a particular
organism cell or tissue we can also
generate genomic data right so a lot of
us
know about genomic data genomic medicine
essentially looking for those mutations
or finding associations between
mutations
and specific types of cancer or specific
stage of cancer or specific treatments
that might be effective or not so that's
called genomics we're looking at
mutations changes in the dna then
there's epigenetics or epigenomics a
rapidly growing field because more and
more we're understanding that
genomic regulation what's written in the
dna
is also regulated by additional elements
like
histone modification like dna
methylation
how chromatin is open or closed and how
accessible it is and many other factors
as well so
a growing area of research that
definitely has an effect on cancer as
well because we know that cancer is
driven by
genetics but also by the environment and
then
transcriptomics where we look at gene
expression
alternative splicing gene fusion and
many
other interactions between mrna
and the mechanisms that are a part of
the translation translation
mechanism that turns the written genes
in the dna
into actual proteins that are being used
and not only is that a useful
proxy to look at proteins but an
important
view of what are the specific biological
processes that are happening right now
in a given
group of cells individual cells tissues
organs
or the full organism and so what is
i think exciting about availability of
this data
is that it provides us with a very
detailed view of
not only the result the product
of what is in the dna but it actually
gives us a snapshot
of what is being done right now so if
you think about
how this affects clinical use
you can imagine that if before we were
looking at
express proteins if we were looking at
histology if we were looking at
morphology of the tissue and differences
in the
phenotype now we can look deeper in
inside every single cell and we can
actually understand what is going on
there
right now so how is this changing cancer
treatment well one important factor is
is that
it is actually right now changing breast
cancer classification as one example so
not only are we looking at uh the
changing
practices in the clinic because of next
generation sequencing data
but we're actually looking at an active
area of research
that makes a lot of these clinical
approaches to treatment
diagnosis and prevention of cancer a
dynamic
area of research and so we're really
looking at now
how we can look at histological
classification
functional classification and molecular
classification together
by integrating multiple types of omics
data through omics
integration but also then how to use
machine learning on
large data sets that we already have
available
to integrate and make sense of this data
in the context of disease classification
but also
for individual patients and i think
that's why
really we're looking at a an
important and a growing role of
bioinformatics and
informatics and data science in general
in this clinical field so
it's really about bridging the early
stage
basic research using this data to
translate this research
to practice and understand how different
aspects of omix data
could be applied in practical clinical
situations
now that's one level of complexity
multiple comics multiple types of
challenges
but another one is that really we need
to connect
how this basic type of research really
connects
to what we see in patients and typically
that means
how do we translate insights from
patient-derived cell lines
to studies that are being performed on
animal models to then the application of
that information for clinical trial
trials and also into the clinic which is
the ultimate goal of genomic medicine so
a good example of that and how
it is changing not only with omix data
but with omix data as well
is this application and here's an
example
where we are looking at existing types
of cancers we're looking at
new types of disease states that we can
identify
and ultimately instead of approaching
that from a typical clinical perspective
we're really looking at a data-driven
perspective where we are trying to uh
actually leverage the availability of
data
and a lot of that data is available in
many different repositories and i'll
briefly mention that
to essentially speed up uh the
the new uh development of treatments
and clinical applications to leverage
that data
treat patients better develop new or
repurpose
drugs to treat the disease better
and also to even prevent data by
understanding better
what are the driving risks behind many
of these
types of diseases so as i mentioned
surprisingly
not only is this data available
the availability of data is growing at a
rapid speed and so what we see
especially in this pandemic right
we've seen how the availability of
genomic data not only is it growing in
volume
it is also growing in how fast it is
becoming available right so if you
imagine
as somebody who is maybe a student or a
clinician
you know where do i get all of this data
right so there's so much data becoming
available
every day that we can mine and
learn from and understand it is amazing
that
we can leverage such expertise
and investment of others into generating
high quality data sets
really generated from like i mentioned
cell lines
animal models as well as patients but
the problem is really
that we need to learn how to navigate
this data right so here in this image
you can see
uh this is mapping of reads to the
reference you know right every single
box right here represents a piece of
data
so working with this data and making it
useful
really extracting some meaningful
insights is challenging
and that is why we can hear about all of
these exciting methods
people you know doing amazing projects
and maybe
integrating a lot of this data and
running all kinds of artificial
intelligence
on it and the problem is that it seems
out of reach
right it is just complex because you
have to deal with
huge amounts of data and very
complicated methods so how do you get
trained how do you get into something
like that
or if you're already in it how do you
expand your horizons so that you can
actually
leverage some of these more advanced
methods and
speed up the process of utilizing
bioinformatics
to actually ask such questions and do
some kind of meaningful work
in this field and so our solution to
this is to
try and make tools for analysis and
integration of this data
more user-friendly and to train people
with the logic behind how these tools
work
so that anyone can play around with big
data sets
analyzing and integrating them together
asking
research questions that make sense and
that will essentially help you
understand both the data and the
computational approaches in a better way
and so what i mean by that is that we
built
the logic of analysis into the toolkit
that we have and we'll talk
briefly about some of the resources that
you'll have access to
in this program where the logic is
explained in courses
and applied in a meaningful way in a
computational
big data analysis platform that you can
point and click
getting quickly from raw data sets to
structured data sets developing tests
and annotating annotating them with
biological information
so that you can quickly go from raw data
available on these public repositories
to biologically meaningful results and
so this kind of annotation
i think provides us with an opportunity
to make
complicated methods that ultimately
are required to make sense of this data
easily
approachable and we can now take
examples
from real studies that will allow us to
ask these questions
and understand what other understand
what others have done for example
availability of the cancer genome atlas
or the tcga
really is one of those examples where we
can
source multi-omics data from 12
different tumor types
with thousands of patients that have
information about their
clinical stage about the different types
of tumors about the different types of
treatments that they received and even
comorbidities in many cases
and start asking meaningful questions
about how
that data could be used to inform the
classification of patients
the treatment strategy the prevention
the risk
right so all of these important
questions could be asked
not only that we will also take a look
at some examples where
cancer studies using patient-derived
cell lines could be used to train
mathematical models using machine
learning and classification
to start predicting different classes
based on signatures
or specific molecular biomarkers
we will also dive deeper into some of
the clinical data for risk factors and
outcomes we'll take a look at
publications and top journals like cell
and
nature medicine that actually show us
how do people utilize some of these
types of data
to come up with new computational
methods but also
how to apply known bioinformatics
approaches that you will learn
in this program to extract meaningful
insights
so cancer obviously is one of those
examples
another example a type of diseases that
we know
is infectious disease is also a growing
area where molecular precision is
becoming more and more informative and
i'll give you just a quick example
we all are hearing about these new
variants
coming up in different strains of
coronavirus all the time
and what we know now is that these
strains
are defined by mutations and those
mutations have a critical impact on the
rollout of vaccines right we actually
hear about that every day in the news
and it's amazing that today genomic data
is so easy to talk about
even though just five years ago you
would start talking about genomic
mutations
and people would just stop listening to
you right so we live in an era of
genomic data becoming more and more
relevant to everything that we interact
with and so this
application of uh molecular biomarkers
and genomic variants to insights that
have a
practical public health and also
clinical impact and significance
is now very obvious so this program is
going to talk about
some applications of computational
methods
to a variety of clinical biomedical
research
pharma and biotechnology challenges
using
big data that is sourced from
peer-reviewed journals
and found in different repositories that
anyone can
get data from and it is going to be
oriented towards
where this field is going and it's
obvious that this field is going towards
big data where data mining and
classification methods
are becoming more and more user-friendly
and easy
to apply to these data sets extracting
meaningful
signal from that data is becoming easier
but at the same time what you really
need is you need the logic of
bridging the gap between the biomedical
and the clinical applications of this
data
to the actual methodology so that the
two can be used together in a meaningful
way
and so in this program we're going to go
through a lot of these examples with
some
also technical practical training that
you can get
access to how to perform many of these
analytical approaches on our big data
analysis platform
including in r and python learning from
curated examples and then developing
a sense of a computational process where
you go from raw data
all the way to biologically meaningful
insights
and taking that with you so that you can
start developing a an environment for
yourself where you can easily
leverage this data for meaningful
biological
and biomedical research and so some of
the outcomes that we
envision for those that are joining this
program is to understand scientific
literature that describes
analysis of omics data to know how to do
basic processing steps for next
generation sequencing data analysis
with consistent accuracy and meaningful
approaches
to perform exploratory analysis and
generate a hypothesis from data
to design contrast for statistical tests
and prepare data for machine learning
annotate found signal using biological
datasets and references
identify appropriate datasets for
answering a biological question
how to plan a bioinformatics analysis
from start to finish
in an independent way and then how to
present a project proposal
including the rationale the methods
scientific background
and anticipated results and so this if
this is relevant for you
and i want to mention that we've
previously had
hundreds of people finish this program
and really taken away
meaningful training skills that they
could later apply
to a variety of challenges that they
face
in their own research and so that
includes
many different participants of different
backgrounds including
high school students that are ambitious
and want to get into a program
with an advanced project that they can
present
includes undergraduates that are
learning something
relevant and really want to get ahead
and maybe want to prepare for their
master's studies or they want to go into
a more
data-driven field that includes phd
students and post-docs
that are now engaged in different types
of data analysis projects and they need
the skill set
and the tools and resources to make
their understanding of that
project more data driven and apply these
tools in a meaningful way
and of course researchers and faculty
that are also
trying to leverage bioinformatics to
make their research more impactful
so now i would like to pass it